Mr. Secretary general.
I appreciate your time.
I want to start with something
that I think
everybody was observing yesterday,
and that was the Victory Day
Parade in Moscow.
There's a lot of attention paid to
just how scaled down it was.
Did you read anything in what we all saw?
Is there something to take away from that
I think we all should be
careful reading too much
into a scaled down parade.
But anyway, it reflects
the fact that Russia has
lost a lot of capabilities in the war
against Ukraine.
We have to remember that this was a war
that President Putin
planned to win within days
and now they have been in Ukraine
for 15 months and they have suffered
heavy casualties.
And and this just demonstrates
the big strategic mistake
it was by President Putin
to to launch this
a war of aggression against Ukraine.
You mentioned the length of the war,
the expectations
at the very start of the invasion,
the durability
and the ability for Ukraine
to succeed up to this point
or to push back
throughout the course of the last
15 months, I think is astonished
most people, if not everyone.
However, Ukrainian officials
have voiced some concern
that the expectations may be a little bit
too high for the counter
offensive concern
tied to
the fact that if there aren't
some sweeping victories
or significant
pushes, that the alliance
that has held together remarkably
well over the course of 15
months supporting
Ukraine may start to wither,
may start to fracture a little bit.
What's your read on that?
President Putin made at
least two big mistakes
when he invaded Ukraine.
One was to total underestimate
the Ukrainian
Ukraine armed forces,
the Ukrainian leadership,
President Zelensky.
But they also told the underestimated
NATO and its allies
and not least the U.S.
leadership
that has been demonstrated
since the invasion
and where in its
allies has provided unprecedented
support to Ukraine
and when its allies and partners have
reiterated again
and again
that we will stand by Ukraine
for as long as it takes.
And this is just demonstrated
this week
with the new announcement
from the United States
more than $1 billion in military aid.
And, of course,
wars are by nature, unpredictable.
But what we have seen
is that
the Ukrainians have been able
to retake territory
before earlier in this war in the north,
in Kiev, in the eastern in Kharkiv
and in the south, again, around Kherson.
And and all the equipment,
all the training
they have received from NATO's
allies and partners,
including a nine brigades trained
and well equipped.
All of this
should enable them
to retake more territory
in their counter-offensive.
At the same time,
we should never underestimate
the Russians
The front lines
have been static for a long time.
And the Russians have been able to build
significant defensive lines
with minefields and
and under
and trenches to
to, of course, counter to the planned
the counteroffensive.
You know,
you mentioned the durability
of the alliance
has probably gotten stronger
and actually larger by at least one
it since the invasion.
But there's another nation, Sweden,
that is also in line to join.
Do you believe Sweden,
which is facing some issues
with at least one member country,
possibly, too,
will be part of the alliance by July
during the NATO's summit
I'm absolutely confident that
Sweden will become a member.
I will work hard to ensure that
that will happen
by the summit.
In Vilnius in July this year.
And we have to remember that regardless
of whether
when that happens,
that they will be a full member Sweden
is in a much better position
now than before they applied because
all allies, also Turkey invited
Sweden to become a member afterwards.
Summit last year in Madrid.
And since then, Sweden
has had the special status
and invite,
meaning that Sweden
is participating
in NATO meetings, structures
integrating more
and more into our civilian
and military structures.
So while I think United States
have issued bilateral security assurances
with Finland
in, if you look at the map,
you know, Sweden is now
surrounded by NATO countries.
So it's absolutely inconceivable
that there would be any
attack or a threat against Sweden
without NATO reacting. So.
So so we have got a long way already
and I hope that we can finalized
accession process
by Vilnius
and let me just add that this isn't
actually a third big strategic mistake
that President Putin made.
He invaded Ukraine
and sent a clear message that he does
doesn't want more NATO
on this borders.
He's getting the exact opposite
is getting more NATO presence in eastern
part of the alliance.
And then he's getting two new members,
Finland and Sweden, and with Finland,
NATO's border
with Russia, more than doubles.
Yeah, it's a dramatic shift.
I do want to ask you before I let you go.
We're learning this morning
that talks are underway
between Naito and Japan to open
a liaison office in the country,
I think would be the first in Asia.
Can you confirm
those talks are happening
with the strategy behind them?
Yes, we are
talking with Japan about opening
an eight office in Tokyo,
and Naito has several offices
in partner countries.
And Japan is a
very close
and important partner for for Naito
and we agreed at the Naito Summit
last year
that we should step up our partnership
with our Indo-Pacific partners
Australia, New Zealand,
Japan, and South Korea.
I recently visited Japan
and the message shared was that
security is not regional anymore.
Security is global.
What happens in Europe matters for Asia
and what happens in Asia matters
for for Europe.
And Beijing is watching closely
what happens in Ukraine
The prize President Putin is paying.
But those are the potential rewards.
So what happens in Ukraine?
Actually,
it matters for the calculations
that Beijing, China is making regarding,
for instance, Taiwan.
NATO's secretary
general, Jens Stoltenberg.
Thanks so much, sir.